[Music]
all right everybody welcome back to
japanese korean news
japanese and korean news that's what it
stands for we don't say nothing about
china fans right big fans
anti-china
i am not that so hire me continuously
wow
wow
oh wow
elon musk's neurolink
has been accused of mutilating monkey's
brains wait what the [ __ ] that sounds
like part of the proposition of starting
it it's like right you got to mutilate
some brain it was like 13 out of 20
something monkeys died or something
right what do they want them to get it
right on the first shot 15
fifteen fifteen yeah oh what uh what
what did they do well so nero lake is
facing legal action from an animal
rights group after claims that the
company carried out quote-unquote
invasive and deadly brain experiments on
test monkeys wouldn't you argue that all
brain experiments are a little invasive
and once you argue that test monkeys are
already labeled test monkeys yeah that's
all we need on it that's why i like when
i go to my like human pile i go test
humans but that's true you know you
don't mix them up the empathetic for the
monkeys and the animal rights let's
really hear out the information and
we'll come to a decision right how many
bananas do so the sci-fi s company was
set up by elon musk in the hopes of
producing a brain implant that could
treat or stop neurodegenerative diseases
sounds pretty low key though that's
pretty cool that's like high key that's
pretty slick if he yeah
down playing elizabeth oh you're right
you're right yeah honestly it's it's all
right yeah we'll see we'll see i'm that
guy yeah doesn't sound bad wanna be a
skeptic for the style of it
i don't know man some people base their
whole personalities i disagree however
the physicians committee for responsible
medicine have spoken out in light of 600
pages of disturbing documents detailing
the treatment of monkeys at the
university of california davis on behalf
of neurolink the documents revealed that
monkeys had had their brains mutilated
in shoddy experiments and were left to
suffer and die that's [ __ ] up that's
really funny but have you guys seen a
chimpanzee with all those [ __ ] brain
things it looks hilarious
hilarious while they're screaming
they're just [ __ ] trying to [ __ ] with
the rubik's cube and [ __ ] they just have
that helmet thing yeah
yeah that's pretty cute now the torture
sucks obviously you know but obviously
it's disclaimer torture sucks i'm sure
the sound of is also not great yeah bro
that must be [ __ ] up i know they quit
all that [ __ ] i thought peter [ __ ]
goes into uc davis and opens up the
chimpanzees in the cages and lets them
loose and [ __ ] exactly although they did
that did we cover a story about how uh
dr fauci was like putting beagles oh
dawg
it was dogs he did experiments on dogs
and he would like part of the experiment
was using flies to land on their
eyeballs
we need to know that yeah that's i don't
know why
but
[ __ ] yeah yeah like what is that
for that's my question but we flip the
names and fauci is doing the monkey
thing
and then elon musk is doing the beagle
thing has a different spin to it yeah so
allegations i can see why he's using
beagles
he's a genius
sorry no i'm no i'm being an idiot
myself so the only thing you can do here
allegations made against neurolink at uc
davis include a lack of adequate
veterinary care for dying monkeys the
use of an unapproved substance called
biol bioglue
that killed monkeys after destroying
parts of their brains and a failure to
look after the psychological well-being
of the monkeys yeah you got to take care
of your ears you like bio glue don't you
you know i've never had it but i'm it's
on my amazon cart what the [ __ ] is bio i
don't know
what's bio it just seemed like a bio
glue guy i just i just went with it
i was like yeah i think they used to
call it liquid band-aid yeah
because i heard super glue was invented
in the war to just patch up wounds you
can you can you can seal up like cuts
and stuff like that with super glue bio
glue sounds like it's for like internal
stuff doesn't it yeah because have you
guys
ruined your [ __ ] fingers like like a
dumb ass as a kid yeah as a kid i think
if you didn't do it you didn't live life
yeah yeah but i hadn't to this day it
was like very nice
that's a lot of this
so i remember going like super glue huh
how super is this you're like oh [ __ ]
and you're trying next minute our mom's
holding it under the water we're crying
damn the only way it's gonna separate is
if the skin rips and then you just do it
yeah and then rips yeah did they find
any success in these experiments through
the sacrifice of these monkeys by the
way um they better have because that's
kind of what determines it right yeah
yeah like if they just failed they're
like inconclusive but all these monkeys
are dead
science needs multiple failures to get
you know that's why they got like they
study with bacteria then okay next step
then with rats then with like mammals
that are closer to humans and then
monkeys and then finally during this
entire near-link process and stuff one
of the first things they had shown was
like um
the kneeling chip implanted in like pigs
and then being able to like understand
and orient certain things and then the
next they passed that phase yeah once it
went past that they put it in monkeys
and then there was this monkey who was
sitting there who was playing pong i
don't know if you guys ever saw that
video and with his mind he's playing
so it's not even like doing some sort of
action it's about like thinking about
what needs to happen in order for it to
be able to contribute it's like if
someone needed an arm that didn't have
one now they can control it exactly so
like there is
there is real world use case possibility
and obviously it is sci-fi-esque for a
reason but like you can't like bart was
saying you can't get to you know point b
without like going from point a to crack
a couple eggs bro
uh you can't get luscious you can't get
luscious hair and shampoo products
unless you test it on monkeys first and
make sure that their hair is nice and
big
all of your all of your hair products
are like you look for the sign that says
like tortured on him with the animals
first you're just like yeah it's like
tested on chimpanzees first dude and
then there's like there should be a
commercial where the like they have a
[ __ ] nice little [ __ ] curl they're
under waterfall
[ __ ] l'oreal chimps yeah
oh yeah that's still frothing at the
mouth because we're worth it too
oh remember didn't they send uh
back in the day before like human test
flights into like space did they send a
dog yeah dogs and then monkeys and like
to like
not even come back like they just left
them out there is it is it fair it was
like a sacrifice i'm pretty sure the
russians did that is it mean to say or
is this fair to say uh rather than
protest
the uh usage of like animals in uh
experiments for products
maybe what if you what if you yourself
refuse to use any product created
throughout history that was rooted in
animal experiment
then you wouldn't be able to use
anything that's a bigger statement
because like let's say the vegetarians
and vegans that i meet that don't buy
cars even with leather seats i'm like
okay that's dope you know you really
stand by you just know animal products
yeah but if you're a vegan and you gotta
[ __ ] lexus and you got like leather
see it's like they're you're kind of
picking and choosing you know that's
that's like you're using the benefits
yeah you're using the benefits that were
reaped from the procedure that you don't
want to happen now that's like the
people protesting about capitalism on
their iphone while they wear nikes and
then they go on their [ __ ] laptop to
[ __ ] talk [ __ ] while they use you
know facebook and [ __ ] or they're like
they're talking about like giving land
back to all the native americans but
then they're still living on theirs it's
like
you're on land you can give
any time yeah i think
look i'm not smart enough to understand
here you are and that's all that
understand yeah
i'm not smart enough to understand
go straight to the ad read please
and this video is brought to you by
herbal essence
it's smart enough to understand it cuts
to like and this is why it's brought to
you by audible you you want to
understand
subscribe to audible now maybe you too
can shampoo that you don't even need to
understand it
no go ahead no it's okay it's done no no
uh
i'm not smart to understand the nuance
of like what needs to happen for this to
work with these monkeys thanks man i
appreciate that but it's also like i'm
not a [ __ ] scientist who am i gonna
tell like i'm not going to tell these
[ __ ] how to do their job but at
the same time could we maybe
try a little bit more ethical yeah like
good we i don't know i don't think i'm a
hotel bed like what well i don't i don't
know what i don't know what's obviously
someone has a dissertation written up
about why like some [ __ ] up things
that are happening here so whatever that
is maybe we could just like dial back
them like maybe they're just taking
these and [ __ ] throw it it's like
it's like farming where it's like yeah
it is it's cruel but like when you see a
[ __ ] farm man just suck a cow for no
reason just while he's doing it's like
come on you need to do that oh my god
you know when you see that what farms
are you on bro they're punching cows you
know yeah they're starving
or they gotta like put they gotta like
get the cow in the thing
just for fun he'll just go
like that ain't gonna make the burger
any better you don't know
hey you don't know let me see the study
bro let's do the comparison study trying
to tend to write i think if you get
called out for it then it's like you
know do you can to like better the
situation but i think yeah
you've got to make your brain you got to
be practical with this like when when
people were giving elon musk [ __ ] for uh
making that kind of semi-blanket
statement to the mars mission and being
like some people are going to die yeah
and people are like i can't believe
you're sending people to their death
they signed up for it
yeah but it's like the most honorable
death you could possibly have they're
saving humanity sorry can you imagine
it's like looking christopher columbus
back then you know what i mean being
like hey every [ __ ] sailor needs to
come back alive on this expedition would
you do it if elon musk was like we need
you anthony you're going to die but
you're going to be if you look to me and
he's like you're going to die i'm like
nah it's cool
i don't need i don't need to be that
right
but if it was even like okay like we
need you
you can die that's totally different
it's like i get to choose to be here
what if he lied he was like you can die
oh he's totally gonna die
he's like
he's a dancer he's gonna believe me not
everybody's gonna make it they like
salute you and they're like oh god damn
oh he's just like look to your left look
to your right somebody's not gonna make
it i'm by myself
and they're like oh this is one of those
death missions
and there's a golden retriever
yeah it's just anthony and monkeys
there's like [ __ ] man he can't
understand the commands that they're
giving each
it's like apollo 13 [ __ ] and all of them
have kendra's bombers on oh
that's fire dude
something actually happened positive for
me in this video let's go that's how
history shows you as the only kinja
cause you're the only one that made it
so the new planet until planet of the
apes and they're all just like
kindreds that was the whole thing i i
needed to go to another planet in order
to really build kindles
look all the monkeys come back doing
this [ __ ] they come back in general
they're way better they're way better
than they peel the bananas like
that becomes the green oh the symbol
becomes this
oh damn ken just dude that's sick that's
the real planet of the apes
that's what it is it's this and then it
goes
that's the next level that's pretty cool
and the subtitle says kenja's oh i'm
pretty happy that's a pretty big move
bro that's really cool damn that's
awesome everyone was right to have
chosen you i think so too you guys are
going to populate moms
[Music]
you